[Music]
my name is abdullah
i am a phone repair store owner today
i'll be showing you the repairs of three
different iphones
in three different conditions they all
have a similar issue a cracked back
glass
the repairs are pretty similar but each
model has
a few different steps
so this iphone 10s definitely has seen
better days
those trunks missing on the top and
bottom those look a little scary
water could get in there debris could
get in there and damage things
but thankfully everything's still
working all right
[Music]
the first thing we'll do for this iphone
10s we'll put it in the laser machine
and we'll burn off the glue that holds
the glass onto the frame
iphones come straight from the apple
factory with adhesive that holds the
back glass down to
the frame and it's my laser machine's
job
to vaporize the glue that's holding down
the glass
to that frame the laser burns at a very
high temperature
enough to go through the glass
completely obliterate the color
standing in its way and melts the glue
straight off the frame
[Music]
so my laser machine has a specific
schematic for each iphone model
it's designed down to a microscopic
level to avoid
any gaps in the frame and strictly go
over the metal once all that adhesive is
vaporized we'll take it out of the laser
machine
and we'll go over to our workbench and
start cracking away this glass
when breaking off the back glass we have
to be super careful
not to let the blade puncture through
the phone and damage an internal
component
i use a series of tools to remove the
back glass
it depends on the damage if an iphone
has
big chunks missing on the back glass and
it has easy access to get underneath
that glass i'll just go ahead with a
blade
similar to a scalpel and i'll go in
there i'll just pry off that glass
as you can see the middle of the phone
still has color in the glass
apple started using glass backs starting
with the iphone 8
because of the wireless charging coil
that's the first model to have the
wireless charging coil
the reason why it needs a back glass is
so that there isn't a piece of metal
that's
affecting the electricity going through
and charging the phone the schematic in
the laser machine specifically
omits the area over the wireless
charging coil
during the second laser run right here
you'll see we're vaporizing
the residual glue left over after
removing the glass
once the second laser round is done
we'll take it back over to our
workstation
and we'll brush off the rest of that
glue
i use a metal brush that gets in and
scrubs that adhesive right off of there
you have to have a surgeon's precision
because if you go in
and get those metal brush teeth into
a gap you could damage a component
now that i've removed all the glass i
can finally start putting the phone all
the way back together
when i'm re-adhering the back glass to
the frame i use industrial strength glue
it's called b7000
straight from the apple factory they use
cold press glue
we try not to get too close to the edges
that way we don't have
a lot of seepage
after the repair is done if there's any
extra glue we'll go ahead and clean it
up with some
glue remover
moving on to the iphone 8 as you can see
this one
it's cracked but it's definitely not as
bad as the 10s it just has hairline
cracks all over the place but thankfully
it's not missing any chunks
so it looks like the inside components
should be fine
so this back glass comes off almost
exactly like how the iphone 10s did
the only difference is with it being the
first iphone that apple used the
backlash on
they actually made the glue a lot
stronger for some reason
so this repair i tend to go a little bit
slower when i'm breaking off the glass
and it tends to fling a lot farther just
because it's on there harder
one key difference with the iphone 8
back glass frustration is that we have
to be careful
around the flash module as you can see
there
there's a big hole to the right of the
camera lens
and unlike the iphone 10s where the
flash is embedded within the camera lens
this one is actually placed off to the
right
and it's exposed
since the laser machine avoids the
wireless charging coil the adhesive
that holds the glass above it is
actually still there so we have to slow
down and use a heat gun
and loosen up that adhesive
[Music]
right here we have the iphone 12 pro max
this gold tends to hide the cracks a
little bit but you can see them
while fixing this 12 pro max we'll
follow the same basic steps
within your backlash repair the key
differences
are the raised glass in between the
camera lenses
and being careful when we're going
around the magsafe components
[Music]
as you can see the glass is a little bit
thicker around the camera lenses
starting with the iphone 11 apple
started producing
back glass with glass that's about twice
as thick around the camera lens
we do face an issue when we're going to
break that glass since it's thicker it
is harder
to get out of there to get it out we
actually have to fragment it
and to do that we have punch tools this
is similar to something that
firefighters use to break a windshield
thankfully
this punch tool is specifically designed
so that it only
breaks it on a surface level and doesn't
create enough pressure to damage any
internal components
with the iphone 12 pro max we face a new
issue and that's the magsafe
there are strips of magnets that go
around the wireless charging coil
and those can be ripped off along with
the glass when you're pulling it off so
you have to be very careful
that we don't rip the wire connected to
those magnetic
[Music]
sections
[Music]
although it might seem like a nightmare
of a process i find it really fun
and it's also very fun to see the before
and afters and that's one of the main
reasons why i do what i do
just to see the transformation of
bringing things back to life